okay I wonder if why is that possible oh
warning this game contains flashlights
very loud noises and lots of jump scares
Lots
I'll be the judge of that hello
everybody my name is Markiplier and
welcome to Locked In sewer update
available
is there well it doesn't seem like it so
this is um this is what we got
whoa whoa
whoa
wow that was some head Bob oh please
tell me that there's a
oh please tell me that there's
oh my God
oh
is this just wait let me go back to the
main menu there's got to be
nope
oh okay well that seems like it maybe
it's better if I crouch nope well a
little bit maybe it's better if I run oh
man it's so wibbly
oh wait a minute hey I'm not ready I'm
still I'm still getting used to the
movement okay maybe it's not as bad as I
think it is for some reason it was
just like EX
[Laughter]
well all right then
so this is a free roam wait a minute
free roam Five Nights at Freddy's game
where you're locked in a sewer I don't
know why I'm in a sewer I don't know why
there's animatronics in the sewer but
there are
and that's something that we have to
deal with we don't get dealt the car oh
my God detected
oh what a wait oh
sh what is that what am I looking at
there what is that
or is that an animatronic
oh my God
what
foreign
I
I guess you're cool then
are you cool
oh man
oh man I don't like this
I don't like this
so
I wonder if why
why is that possible
oh my God okay
that's fair that's fair okay so I think
I I I think I just backed myself into a
corner with that one
um
yeah maybe I was overreacting the the
head Bob doesn't seem as egregious as it
was before it is still a little wobbly I
think it's the fact that it moves like
in every direction
okay so he's coming down there
So eventually
I suppose okay if I draw him
over here so come take a look at me
all right
my god oh frick oh frick oh my God
oh I'm dead
oh my God that was a whole other way to
go here
[Music]
oh my God
you know you could leave me alone at any
moment now you could even leave me alone
you could I I well there's no Escape for
me or anybody oh look
um well
like most things in my life that went
poorly I'm just gonna keep going this
other way that I didn't know existed
and then I'm gonna find a wrench
why I don't know is it my job to be down
here
because I feel like if it was I would
have a wrench
I feel like that's crucial to me
completing my task
so therefore
shouldn't I have a
wrench
the light from an animatronic or what
oh
that's a little I was just standing in a
long hallway I see okay well all right
you know I feel like I don't deserve
this but all right no okay okay all
right no man you could not do any of
this okay
okay so what I discovered was that just
kind of loops around could I go home now
so the moral of the story is don't
Meander your way across long hallways
because uh he might be there
waiting
where were you whoa whoa what is that
wrench
I'm guessing wrench
close all the vowels
great
how am I supposed to get 16 of these
can you hear when I do one of these or
something
I'm out
okay
so you Patrol
where you hear this noise but the
problem is I don't know which direction
you're going to be coming from
oh frick
it's gonna get I'm gonna get can I get
across the way
fighting I'm gonna hide
hide
[Music]
not this way
and this way no no no no
yes yes yes
no
no no no
I'm gonna make a break for it here we go
I'm going oh he was looking all right
oh why did you crouch when you should
have ran
this is entirely your own fault
actually I blame the developer for not
putting uh for not putting in the
ability if you're crouching and you hit
the Run button it should lift you out of
the Crouch and you should go but I guess
not okay I don't know if I'm gonna be
able to beat this one because I'm too
stupid to succeed and I doubt that
wrench is going to be in the same place
that it was before I know that you can
get away from him because I've done it
before
the wrench is definitely not there
okay
don't look at me detected not for long
there we go
so I'm just guessing that as I progress
as I get more of these valves
it's going to get a little harder
because it's going to wake up more of
the animatronics and then they're all
gonna come running for me every time I
open a valve
isn't that true
okay well I don't know where the
wrench is
I don't know where I am
where where does this go
oh wrench
oh really right why why why why why why
why why
nice he'll never find me
foreign
try to catch me
a little closer than I'd like
got that one
oh frick oh frick oh frick oh frick
yeah almost too easy I thought this was
going to be a challenge okay I'm not
gonna do that one because that would be
foolish you're not awake are you
good
keep it that way
oh man this head Bob is starting to get
to me it's just it's just a little too
much that's a thing it's just on the
edge of
too much it seems like you know it's
it's just a bit nausea inducing because
I've always found head Bob to be nausea
inducing I I know the argument that a
lot of people will have to be like oh
it's immersive and I'm like it really
really doesn't seem immersive
oh from the frick no Frick oh he's
really close and he's got speed oh oh
God
[Music]
oh I'm gonna lose him in the turns
where's the turn there's the turn
no oh God damn it
I'm gonna lose him in the turns I'm
gonna lose him in the turns ah
I didn't lose him in the turns this game
is good
oh thank goodness the wrench is there it
reminds me a lot of vanish in a way
um and having free roam animatronics is
always cool in my book
but at the same time it is it's just
like a little too much
it's just slightly it's not terrible but
it is just like
a little hard to play for a long period
of time and it's one of those things
where it's like yeah this is gonna take
some attempts this is gonna take some
tries
um and if I just don't have the uh
stomach to be able to try then it's
gonna be tough but I'm gonna give this
one last go if I can't get them all on
this one which seems you know why did
that say detected
oh
and then um
I don't think I'm gonna be able to make
this
okay I can get away with this one I can
get away with this one
because I'm on a run oh no don't do it
no lose your momentum oh my God what is
that about what is that about all right
kill me kill me kill me do it kill me
all right uh uh uh
okay so I'm gonna end this one here it's
a little earlier than I ordinarily would
this type of game that needs like
multiple attempts I feel like I could
beat it and I feel like I want to beat
it I just wish there was an option to
turn off head Bob it is it's just a
little nausea inducing and I can only
imagine for people watching out there
but if there's like just just one little
setting because I know that there's
other animatronics here I know there's
other things to see and I want to see
them it's a little bit too much just a
tiny bit too much so thank you everybody
so much for watching let me know what
you thought down in the comments below
and if I if there is an update I might
just play it anyway but this is good
very good thank you and as always I will
see you in the next video bye-bye
[Music]
thank you